[Music]
time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week first up
the benefits of a better diet most of us
are aware there's a relationship between
our food choices and our overall health
but what's the real impact over time
newly published research from the New
England Journal of Medicine examined
data from two large studies they looked
at the relationship between the quality
of one's diet and risk of death by using
three different dietary scoring methods
they found a 20 percentile increase in
diet scores was associated with an 8 to
17 percent reduction in deaths here now
with more on this study a CBS News chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook and
CBS News contributor dr. Tara Narula
Tara take us through some of the results
from this study so this was a very large
study they looked at about 70,000
participants and they assessed their
diet quality with the scores as you
mentioned over a 12-year period and then
they looked for a 12 year subsequent
period to see what the death rates were
and they found a couple things they
found that those people who had the
poorest scores at baseline and improved
the most at a 15 to 28 percent decrease
in their mortality those people who had
consistently high levels of diet scores
decreased their mortality 9 to 14
percent and on the other hand those
people who had declining diet quality
increased their mortality by about 6 to
12 percent so what is the real takeaway
from this it's a couple things one is
that this is really about healthy
dietary patterns not about one single
nutrient they looked at things like the
Mediterranean diet and the DASH diet the
second is that small changes can have a
big impact so the authors of the paper
discussed this idea that even some
swapping out or substituting out red
meat or processed meat one serving a day
and switching it with legumes and nuts
you can improve your diet quality by
about 20% and the last is that it's
never too late because the majority of
participants were over 60 years old well
that's very interesting John well is
there a difference between say if you
just do this for a couple of years and
if you do it over a longer period of
time yeah as you would expect the answer
is yes so if you kept it up for eight
years mortality went down 11% you kept
it up for 16 years it went down 26% and
if you think we'll what
to study to show us that I cannot tell
you how many patients over the years
when I say you know you need to adjust
your diet they'll say well wait it's
gonna turn out that like in sleeper in
that Woody Allen movie that in the
future it's gonna turn out that deep
fats good for you and it's you know you
may think it's obvious but it's great to
have the data Tara what are some of the
characteristics of the people that
improved their diets over time so those
that improved seem to be younger they
were more physically active they
consumed less alcohol when you looked at
what they were eating no big surprise
they increased the number of whole
grains or the amount of whole grains in
their diet
increase the vegetables the fruits the
omega 3s or the fish that they consumed
and they decrease things like sodium
processed meat or red meat and sugary
beverages it feels like we hear the same
thing and are just constantly reminded
we need to do it our next topic actually
deals with cancer and the social impact
it can have on adolescents and young
adults the study was published in the
journal cancer it examined the social
functioning of this age group within 2
years of their cancer diagnosis there
were 215 participants at the start with
a hundred and forty-one completing the
follow up survey 2020 four months later
all were between the ages of 14 and 39
John this is something we haven't seen a
lot of studies on the social effects of
cancer was one of the big findings here
well as you might expect they tend to
bottom out in terms of their social
function at the time of diagnosis in the
next year they climb up but then they
kind of level off for the next year and
I knew nothing about this until about
five or six years ago I met a guy named
Matthew Zachary who at 21 was diagnosed
with brain cancer started a group called
stupid cancer as a support group and I
learned that in this group it's not
pediatrics it's not older they have very
special problems so sexuality you going
on your first date what do you say when
do you say it you want fertility you go
into the job interview who do you say to
when they need support groups and it's
really great that now this is getting
the attention it deserves you feel like
you touched on some of them there but
did they sort of figure out some of the
reasons for the social issues so the
interesting they found that nearly 32
percent had persistently low level of
social functioning throughout the period
that they were studied and when they
looked at issues involved a lot of it
was people who were off treatment and so
I think the big issue here is that even
though you may have been cured of your
cancer there are survivorship issues
things where you're worried about
negative impacts on financial situations
on your relationship on whether you're
gonna be able to have kids your body
image on what your work plans are going
to be so I think one of the big
takeaways is that we need to have
support not just for people during the
time of their treatment but in terms of
reintegrating them back into their life
when they have become a survivor
were there other recommended strategies
for this jump in terms of dealing with
us yeah one of them is you know support
group well it should be in your age
group yeah you don't want to have
somebody who's 18 go into a support
group whether somebody who's 90 there's
a different set of issues and things
that you would expect intuitively
obvious like in the hospital have places
that are pleasant you know have for the
kids have games things that are like you
know things that they like to do not
things that somebody again who is 60 and
then again understanding as Tara was
saying that there are special issues so
you may survive the cancer and then
later on have even secondary medical
issues in the past they didn't survive
to get the secondary medical issues
problems with their heart and other
problems so it's great that this is
getting focus on it now and we need to
really specifically address these issues
all right finally a new take on wearable
technology one that can translate motion
into words new research in a journal
published by the public library of
science looked at a new glove that can
decode the American Sign Language
alphabet it then transmits the words to
electronic devices the glove was created
by researchers at the University of
California San Diego it costs less than
a hundred dollars to make and the study
authors believe the technology will have
multiple applications in the future one
word wow that is just wonderful and
thank you to Caitlin Luna from Gallaudet
University who taught me how to say
amazing the difference that just a bit
of technology can live forever
that's six four opens up the world and
connects us all doctors Jon LaPook and
Tara Narula thank you very much